[Music]
all right we obviously have to talk
about gun control this week over the
course of my many Rubin report
interviews I've sat across from an array
of people who are pro-gun rights
anti-gun altogether or somewhere in
between
while the events surrounding the gun
conversation are always horrific with
this week's tragic events in Vegas being
perhaps the worst of all of them I
believe that the conversation around
guns when done right can offer powerful
insight into how people think about
society at large gun ownership and the
right to bear arms brings up issues
about the American Constitution states
rights personal responsibility mental
health radicalization both religious and
otherwise and much more unfortunately as
is so often the case these days we're
seemingly caught between two groups of
people the people who want to ban guns
completely and the people who don't want
to have any sort of conversation about
sensible gun laws well I absolutely
support the Second Amendment I at the
same time understand and acknowledge
that the United States has what seems to
be a unique problem related to mass gun
violence lost in the midst of all the
awful events of Las Vegas this week are
other senseless shootings across the
country like the five people killed and
30 others wounded by gunfire in Chicago
this past weekend the weekend before
that three were killed and 36 were
wounded in Chicago and the weekend
before that it was 11 dead and 29
wounded in the very same city we've
included a link down below which tracks
the gun related violence across Chicago
occurring every single weekend and it's
disturbing to say the least I bring up
Chicago not to deflect from the events
in Las Vegas but to show how this
murderous violence is happening in one
of our biggest cities literally every
single day and happening so often at
this point that the mainstream media has
all but given up on reporting on it the
reasons behind how and why people murder
others also makes it hard to find one
law around guns that works in every
situation there no doubt is a difference
between a murder that occurs during a
robbery versus gang violence versus
terrorism versus suicides versus a
random shooter with no known political
or religious motive
and at the same time there are times
when someone with the gun saves innocent
lives during a shootout or when someone
defends their property and their family
by having a gun in the home so again
while I support the Second Amendment I
also recognize that we undoubtably
have a gun related violence problem on
our hands just look at the numbers I can
also acknowledge that guns in and of
themselves aren't the only problem here
without question much of the carnage
caused by guns is due to people with
mental health issues gaining access to
guns the truth is that if I or most of
the gun owners in America had access to
the most deadly weapons on earth
we wouldn't be randomly using those
weapons against innocent people not only
are mental health issues an aspect to
the people who are committing mass
shootings but also there's a problem
with any any ideology which drives
people to commit these heinous acts be
it a religious ideology a political
ideology or any other system of
principles or beliefs which could drive
someone to kill a weapon in and of
itself can't kill anyone it takes a
human being and a corrupt thought
process to pull the trigger and kill
innocent people also as I'm recording
this it's still unclear exactly what
weapons were used in Vegas but
authorities report to finding about 20
other firearms in the shooters hotel
room and it's possible that this man was
using a military-style fully automatic
rifle to commit this heinous act for all
the defense I've offered up the Second
Amendment I cannot see I can't possibly
see how access to such weapons which
have the ability to mow down civilians
at an incredible rate and which are
designed for the battlefield should be
in the hands of regular citizens as we
post this video the story about the
Vegas gunman is largely incomplete at
the moment we don't seem to know his
motives so it's hard to say if this was
an act of terrorism under the most
specific definition of the term which
includes having a political motivation
to kill Nevada States definition is a
little more broad not including the need
for a political motivation which in this
case would in fact classify this killer
as a terrorist regardless of how we
wanted to find this specific act of
horrific violence or how the gun
discussion relates to terror
or the legitimate right of every citizen
to have the ability to defend themselves
we must get better about talking about
gun control between the shootings in
order to prevent more shootings and not
just talk about it when these acts occur
passing more laws in the heat of emotion
is rarely the right thing to do even if
they are well intentioned while doing
nothing and hoping that these events
will simply end is just as misguided as
hoping the Terrorism will completely
stop if we just ignore it while we wait
to find out more about the Vegas shooter
himself and at the same time mourn the
victims of this evil act
we should also continue to talk to
people on both sides of the gun debate
to try to come to some sensible place of
agreement I'm gonna do my best to do
just that and if you guys know of some
interesting voices in this debate that
you'd like to hear on the Reuben report
let us know in the comment section right
down below
[Music]
you